Hey Youtubers happy Super Bowl weekend so we got
new transformers let's break it down gladiator
robots fighting for the future of Cybertron
and the Earth.
This just feel so appropriate Super Bowl weekend
if you have no idea what's going on.
Don't worry.
It just like a comic con style weekend when
a whole bunch of trailers are dropping, so
be sure to subscribe to get everything I'll
be doing a couple fun giveaways.
I'll remind everyone at the end of this which
other big trailers have been confirmed when
they're coming, but you can kind of see like
is Optimus prime is fighting bumblebee here
there sort of setting them up for his spinoff
movie, there will be a bumblebee standalone
film, in addition to all these Saga transformer
films so that just paints a little clearer
picture that Optimus prime is positioned as
the villain in the same way that Dom is the
villain of the fast and the furious movie.
This can be happening, really soon to that
they released the synopsis and Michael Bay
did this big interview about the crazy writers
room that they had about spinning the mythology
out for this big film universe that they're
doing because the be this bumblebee standoff
film then the be doing their saga films, so
they basically had to reengineer the transformers
mythology, so that it would fit within this
giant film universe, so they had everybody
that had ever worked on transformers come
in and explain the mythology to them.
So just read the synopsis here the last night
shatters the core myths of the transformers
franchise.
So they're talking about the movies the toys
all the stuff that they've done so far redefines
what it means to be a hero.
Humans and transformers are at war Optimus
prime is gone.
Like you see them floating off in space in
the trailer.
The key to saving our future lies buried in
the secrets of the past in the hidden history
of the transformers on earth.
So that's where we see the transformers during
the time of King Arthur we see this Dragon
transformer flying around saving our world
falls upon the shoulders of an unlikely alliance,
Cade Yeager who's Mark Wahlberg's character
for the most recent film, bumblebee an English
Lord who's Anthony Hopkins character in an
Oxford professor.
That's Laura Haddox character.
There comes a moment in everyone's life when
we are called upon to make a difference in
transformers the last night the hunted will
become heroes, so the talking a little bit
about Megatron with his giant sword here.
He actually looks really bad ass in this movie
the new character.
This young girl here with the squeaks robot
she's going to be stepping up becoming a hero
in heroes will become villains talking about
Optimus prime poisoned by the dark Energon
OneWorld will survive their ears or hours
so that just confirms that this planet is
basically the remains of cybertron from the
previous films not the last one.
It was transformers dark of the moon where
they basically teleported the remains of cybertron
into outer space.
They were going to replace the earth with
that.
So what they've done is instead of like doing
a completely different story for the sequel
is they sort of leave the mythology of all
the films that have come so far and sort of
recontextualize it Optimus prime at the end
of the last movie went looking for the creator's
mysteries to the universe's all about who
we are and why we are here are not among them.
Those answers we carry inside.
I am Optimus try this messages to my creator
planet Earth will because I'm coming for you
if you been watching transformers for a long
time they have a couple creator myths in Primus
is the original creator of the transformers
is like this multi-verse will being that exists
inside the center of cybertron is that the
special computer that sort of like webbed
into everything that the transformers are
so when Optimus prime said that he's seeking
redemption in here that female voice he might
be in the bowels of cybertron.
So when it sound like they're playing with
the core myths of the transformers franchise
it sound like they're playing with their creation
myth.
So Optimus prime gets co-opted by the forces
of cybertron try and renew their planet at
the expense of the earth.
So it looks like sometimes passed since the
last film, and there's been all out war between
the transformers in the humans.
So when the time that Optimus prime blasted
off at the end of the last movie things just
got completely nuts.
I just love reading through Michael Bay's
interview talking about how they brought in
transformers historians anything like super
sentai or Power Rangers that have been around
for long time always has experts that rise
up so you could see like a bunch of transformers
professor sitting around the table talking
about the mythology.
It just sounds so cool if you've heard of
the Lucasfilm archives were they keep everything
Star Wars.
They made a version of that for the transformers
franchise it for all the big films for all
the stuff of the going to be doing so I would
be surprised if there is like a giant resurgence
of transformers and pop-culture it's always
been pretty popular but typically what you
see is you have like a bunch of young kids
the get hooked on the new animated series
going to see the movies.
So let me know what you think of that so far
in the cool thing is is they will be releasing
a longer version of this on Sunday, so I'll
do another video the be a bunch new footage
and let me know what you think about the new
trend in movies with heroes going bad for
good reasons they are totally explain what
you can see the reaction they're going for
from the trailer like they want you to freak
out because Optimus prime is trying to kill,
bumblebee he is the dark energon, but clearly
he's still a good character so the neck in
a make him.
He redeemable so it seems like in his failure
the forces of cybertron give him a second
chance but in doing so also turn him bad for
little while it's like the classic transformers
felt were the defeated Megatron comes upon
you and a chronic gets a second chance and
becomes Galvatron.
So it almost seems like this is a reverse
version of that for Optimus prime, so him
and have to spend some time this weekend re-watching
the animated movie it's been a while been
watching some of the live-action movies to
get I super Bowls, here it is gonna be a bunch
also trailers this is just the beginning the
be some guardians of the galaxy the other
big trailers that are dropping our pirates
which is another paramount movie, just like
transformers, there's more fast and furious
and then obviously guardians of the galaxy.
So as those post that will post new videos.
So they might be dropping across the weekend.
They might all drop on Sunday will try to
do is many of them as possible.
And there will be Marvel giveaways when I
post is Marvel videos, but there will be some
new Star Wars episode 8 later tonight while
you wait for that to post you can click here
to learn which guardians have been confirmed
for infinity war and you can click here for
my Star Wars episode 8 snoke video thank you
so much watching everybody thought five I'll
see the next video!